what's up guys this is eric griffin and
i want to give a big
shout out to helix sleep take their two
minute sleep quiz and they'll match you
to the mattress that will give you the
best
sleep of your life find your perfect
mattress at helix helixsleep.com
griffin
you have a small head you've ever seen
a helmet doesn't even fit me yeah you
have a small head i remember when i was
looking for my
motorcycle helmet when i was younger and
like i couldn't find a woman's helmet
that fit me i almost had to go child
size
so it's just like jeans and helmets
don't fit you
i'm a very petite woman other than long
right okay hold on wait wait
actually my mom used to shop in the
petite department because
i never understood why until
she told me she's petite
she's a petite tall woman
that's different because your grandma
doesn't look like she's like petite like
that my grandma
is shorter than my mom though oh really
but i don't think i don't i don't know
i think her my grandma's mom was really
small i think
really i'm not sure i i've i've only
seen pictures
you've seen pictures of your grandma's
yeah
it's gonna be weird it's gonna be weird
how like people are gonna be able to
like look back on the next generation is
gonna have like all the instagram
footage and facebook and myspace and all
those pictures are going to be there
millions of pictures you know
yeah right but i mean especially like
for
one day knock on wood but when we have
kids
um like they're going to look on all
our instagram facebook and be like oh my
god they have
hundreds of pictures or they're going to
be like mom yeah
you're going to be embarrassing
whereas like my even my parents aren't
really on
social media or even my brothers aren't
so like
yeah that's that's that's that you're
like there's still a generation that's
like not on there
yeah your parents are from yeah they're
not but it's also like a job thing too
like you know my mom's a teacher so she
doesn't want her students
finding any weird pictures
what weird pictures of you would your
mom even have on the internet i don't
know even my cousin is a teacher and she
still isn't into social media because of
they don't want to get fired
oh for like posting
something something like center property
yeah
okay well first of all i want or are we
gonna sing
well i was going to start like that but
you you just we just started
so we'll do it at the end again okay so
if you guys are looking for the intro
it's going to be at the end this is like
a
hot take rachel's taking over the
podcast today so go ahead rach
welcome to riffin with griffin
um with his co-guest
my co-host or co-guest no co-guest for
me that i'm a guest
on my own podcast
i guess we should i guess we could just
do it right in the middle of it right
here like this
okay should we just do it right in the
middle let's do it okay here we go
[Music]
all right rachel you had a big showing
last time
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
i didn't redeem myself it's okay you'll
figure it out you'll come on a lot until
you get it right until
just maybe it'll be just be you on here
you don't need the headphones anymore if
you don't want okay you put the
headphones down
uh i guess i don't need a headphones
either all right so here we are
um so you know rach you've been on the
you've been on the podcast a couple
times
and then like you know we were going
through the comments you know
you did tell me before we even recorded
don't look at the comments
don't look at them just move on with
life
you know so i did take that into
consideration for a few days
and then i looked at the comments
oh my god everyone thinks i'm a gold
digger yeah they all think you should
dump me
yeah i know it's like the big word was
red flags there's so many red flags
about this
oh my god okay first of all
i was very embarrassed when i said it's
glad to be back
okay i speak english but you were just
nervous
i'm i'm still a little nervous why do
you get nervous why are you nervous
about this
do i make you nervous is it my fault
yeah why
you just act different and it makes me
uncomfortable because i'm not used to
you acting like this
oh so like you're saying that like i
have like a podcast persona
and then and i tell you to be
comfortable but you're like i don't know
who this person is how can i be
comfortable because you're not even
being yourself
yeah all right okay i'll take that i'll
take the hit for that one
but um i think it's also
the lights the camera knowing i'm
speaking to all your fans not my fans
right well even though i don't have many
you do
there's like four guys on your facebook
that always
they're my loyal fans since day one
they've been there eric rachel has some
of these weird guys that follow her on
facebook
from like one there are some like
foreign countries and they
they comment on every single post every
single picture
okay and okay i want to just get it out
there i'm not a singer
that's like she's not a singer or a
wrestler so i'm trying hard
no but you know actually it was to me it
was very cute it was sweet what you did
the first
time it was like so vulnerable and i i
a lot of people there was a lot of great
comments about that really i didn't get
to those
i know you know what's funny is when you
look at the comments you're only seeing
the negative ones and you're like
you just focus on those and i tend to do
that a lot too like when i'm streaming
and stuff like that
like i always get a comment from stop
stop talking to the trolls griff stop
talking to the trolls
there's other people that love you but
you know you just as a you know you're
i guess they're not the ones commenting
saying like great job
right right they're not it's only the
other people they're really like
this is [ __ ] yeah and it's so like
yes so you know what i always say like
because even on your
on your instagram or anybody's instagram
comments
it would be like your parents are
talking about you
and you're in the room and they're kind
of talking at you condescendingly
but you're sitting right there that's
what comments are you know people say
rude things they don't think that we see
that
it's like it's you know i think they
want you to see it
obviously but it's like sometimes you
just go dad what kind of person are you
to say
this kind of weird stuff let me just put
this to bed too rachel's not a gold
digger because if she was she wouldn't
be with me
i know y'all see me on tv and i've been
on shows and stuff but if you think i
live in a mansion
have you seen my cooking show i have a
little kitchen she complains about my
place all the time
yeah i mean we could go on a long
tangent about being a gold digger and
what i would be into
if i was yeah yeah yeah i would live in
malibu
yeah i would have a mansion i would
at least have money to go shopping
anytime i wanted to
i i would be wearing jewelry i would
have an engagement ring
okay let's tone it down now this is
starting to get hurtful
i'm just saying like money isn't what's
important to me
even though it does help with life i
mean
i just so you know i never thought that
i just i know because i know what it
looks like
i get it yeah i get what it looks like
but people don't know our journey behind
the scenes
yeah and i just want you to write first
episode you're talking about 800 jeans
no no no but let me just second episode
you're talking about a
promised car i know it's partly my fault
you're right but i just want you to know
just
personally and publicly i never thought
that i
just because of how our interaction has
always been i
mean i know like just as like a
model who's dating an older guy a lot of
people already
yeah yeah yeah we're already in the hole
yeah i
already assumed you're taking care of me
they don't know i have a job
yeah you know what's funny i don't know
i have two jobs they also don't know
that you're
you know well you've already said your
age so many times so it doesn't matter
but like look you know how many times
people say to me yeah i wouldn't be
working if i were to
dig no you know how many times people
say to me oh she's not 22.
she's not i thought she was 20 something
you know and i just go
nah she she in her 30s
she just looks great thank you she does
a face routine that she does every
single night even wearing makeup and
that's
now they're all going to zoom in yeah
you know you just you rachel you're very
beautiful okay
you're naturally beautiful and you're
gonna be beautiful a long time it's
making me like well i'm down i'm down
you know i'm down 25 pounds and i want
to go even further my goal is
on our honeymoon i could have my shirt
off and not be embarrassed
you know i love you how you are now
how you have been when i first met you
like your looks isn't what's important
to me and i always thought you should
just be confident
with your shirt off i am but um i want
to be healthy
yeah no i get it and like i understand
that
just a few pounds off could make a huge
difference in your confidence
and it already has i've seen the
difference well for me it's like you
know i have that scar that i've had from
birth
yeah you know so i have like a guys i
have a scar on my
i had a i had a disease when i was born
called her sprung
i think it's called her sprung but
anyway it's an intestinal disease
so like they had to cut off some of my
intestines when i was a baby
and i had to wear a colossal bag for
like the first six months of my life
but anyway there was a scar that was on
the side but as i grew it it went to the
middle now when i was younger and i was
fit and i was playing basketball and i
was in my early 20s
it was like it didn't matter it just
looked like a scar but what happens is
when you gain weight you get fat
it like the scar stays there and then
this the stomach
it looks like i have a front booty you
know what i mean it's like so it cuts in
the middle there
so i want to so that has made me
self-conscious
uh my whole life uh and so like you know
this when you're around someone and you
you you feel that way you're like oh i
don't want them to see me naked i've
always felt like that so
recently in my recent life and last 10
years is when i started i was like ah it
is what it is this is who i am whatever
but yeah i would like it to be like you
don't get stares
you know yeah and people like oh what's
wrong with that guy's belly
you don't want that this is the time
though in life
that everyone is mo the most accepting
and i think people know not to just
stare i mean
if anything it's kids that like even
like at my job
like a family will come in and
even if it's like a a weird looking
parent or something
and they'll see me and be like oh that
lady's big and it's like i'm not big
but like you know they'll say like a
comment like that
and it's like it will get to you and
it'll be like
like i guess people think i'm big
well to them a little bit exactly to a
little kid but it's like
it's like it's weird how
it can affect you um just from like
one word or like one sentence from
someone
in your life i think kids are honest
though that's why i do love that about
kids they will be like
you know it's like if if somebody's fat
a kid is quick to be like that person's
fat look how fat that person even if
they're not saying it mean they're just
like like they're saying it
inquisitively just to be like
wow why is that person so fat you know
they kind
yeah we all want answers to why people
are fat well so
at least now you're people are starting
to
like you're opening up about it so now
if they do see a photo of you with your
shirt off they're going to be a little
more understanding
i don't know i think these trolls out
here are still going to be mean as [ __ ]
yeah true people are people are just me
median so you'll always have people
yeah yeah yeah yeah people it's funny
when you're comedian people think it's
okay
probably in the same way like being a
model there's some expectation where
it's like well you always have to be
in model mode or they have like some
sort of like things about models what's
the same thing with comedians it's like
you know people say all these like rude
mean things to me all the time they
don't realize that
it can't come across rude and mean just
but just because i'm a comic you think i
you think the first thing i want you to
say to me is like oh hey fatty or hey
like you know
so you think i like that you know what i
mean i mean it's an easy dig
yeah that's why i would say be funny
like if you want to come at me if you
have a funny fat joke
be funny but a lot of times people just
regurgitate what somebody else says
like like bobby lee he he always he used
to say
hey fat black that's what he would say
like he's trying to be funny
on his on the podcast and he would say
that well all the minions of bobby lee
every time they come on they're like hey
black and i just go ha ha ha ha oh
that's so funny
to hear the same joke said a million
times or like or whatever
dumb joke it is and it's like after a
while you just go okay
all right this is not even hurtful it's
just annoying
it's just you know at what point is it
at what point you're gonna be like
what's your own original
i get it because like my whole life i've
been tall so like every comment
i get from people is like oh you're so
tall did you know you're tall
like it's like yeah i could look in the
mirror
like i could see that you're shorter
than me like you know like
like and then it comes to a point where
it's like you're sick of hearing it
okay i know i'm tall bye
[Laughter]
or then you start coming up with jokes
oh so not everyone gets this tall like
you didn't get the
growth hormone oh so you're all you see
that's funny that you took that approach
or like my dad used to always say like
because he's six nine yeah her dad is a
giant she used to say like oh
you better drink your milk oh
for me i so i have a big nose you can't
tell that i have a big nose
because my face and body is caught up to
my nose well your nose and ears will
yeah well my no my nose has been this
size since age
three so can you imagine really i'm just
letting you know
my nose is not going to get bigger yeah
it gets bigger who is this
your ears and your nose as long as is
this from they say is this from they
say.com
rachel's big on that it's a thing they
say no
well anyways my point is whenever that's
why people get nose well when i was a
kid no because they've had a big nose
their whole life when i was a kid
it was like a whole thing because i was
really skinny i was like we're super
skinny so then my nose was like half my
face size
so it's just like always every jokes
when it came time to like you know
you're in school you meet new people you
know you get on the
playground the first thing is like you
got a big nose and it starts and
everybody's going with it so
it was all in my childhood until i got
into high school i was in high school
and mean things were happening but it
was just one day i was in the parking
lot of
with my friends you know we're all
driving out whatever and somebody made
some big nose joke at me and then i made
a joke back at them about my big nose
and we all laughed and it was the first
time i was like oh
this is not that serious like i i'm i'm
being sensitive about this and i don't
you know so i made fun of it myself you
know we all have something so your thing
was because you were probably taller
than every boy
in an elementary school though i was
made fun of
because i was skinny too and so
girls started being like you have
anorexia
you have an eating disorder and that
this was before i even knew what an
eating disorder was you know so i'd go
home and like
look it up and be like like why do they
think i
am bulimic you know and like and
i'd like feel bad yeah yeah but then i'd
see
like now i'm gonna cry i'd see like
cindy crawford
i'd like tyra banks i'd see
all these other models that were skinny
that kind of had my same body type
and i kind of grew up almost thinking
like i could do that
because they did that and they look like
me and like
i could also like be successful
with what i look like yeah i know jack
which means it's okay babe
this this is like i'm so i'm so used to
this rachel rachel will start
crying at the like we'll be watching the
television show
i don't know what's going on on the
television show it's a dumb show but if
something touching moment happens she
will start crying but it's okay babe
you did it look at you you're here now
you know and this so for all you out
there if you're skinny out there you're
tall and skinny you know
you know it's just we all have some kind
of particular body thing and we just
feel shamed or we like you know
why why is there something wrong with me
and it's weird how we had that mentality
but now you're you're here now and
you're like whatever
[Laughter]
people listening to the podcast thank
god they're not watching youtube
a mess right now
you're fine my whole face is wet
no you're good you're good because she
gets you get so nervous that you say you
get nervous here and i
cause i like i said earlier i was saying
like i was like rachel just be yourself
just relax
and then you get on here and you get
nervous but i think you feel more
comfortable now
when i like don't pay attention
look over here at you we're playing
flitzy over here
yeah we had a great zoom call today with
uh rachel's family we do that every
week i've talked about it on the podcast
before
grandma's uh i love your grandma she's a
sharp lady she asks a lot of questions
yeah when you're not on like where's
eric
because she likes to get into politics
too she'll go into it and the rest of
your family is kind of like i don't know
you have this i love all your family but
they're a little they're
they're a character for sure but i could
tell your grandma was like hard
she was like was she do you think she
was tough when they were growing up
yeah she still is tough on like me and
my cousin
oh really how so
this let's start putting the counter
rachel oh you're doing the drinking game
rachel cries you take a shot
um so i forgot how old i was but maybe
like
around 25 and like my
i think she was like moving from
pennsylvania to florida so
taking all her like stuff she's had
forever
and like giving it away or selling it
right
you know because you can't take it all
in because they were downsizing like
yeah it was like a
four-story house with like
i i don't know tons of room because they
she had four children so like there's
tons of rooms filled with stuff
and then um now she lives in a one
bedroom
right in one of those communities in
florida
yeah so um there were
a few like winter jackets that i was
ooh i would love to have these grandma
and she was like
you know i would love to give them to
you but
you um have to be successful first
like when you are successful i'll give
you these jackets damn
grandma put down the gauntlet i was like
what does successful mean like
like i'm a model like yeah you know i
i was working i you know felt like 25
i was a woman who could wear a jacket
yeah you're like you're like i can wear
my grandma's jacket at 25 i'm getting
paid to be a model
but yeah so she she held on to it
for a little bit and i had to like
but you eventually got him yeah i did
the fur coat nice fur coat but she gave
me a lecture she's like well
success means like to ask anyone for any
thing you're living you know on your own
and that you know
politics and that
about all these topics you know and i
think that was her definite
success like like you know
yeah she's a little even marriage family
who knows but she's had it all so like
she
and she's had you know her four kids all
very successful yeah they are
they are they they very much are uh yeah
one's an author a lawyer i don't even
know what josh what did he do
he um he was in he was a lawyer too
right he was in the business he took
over the business though dude
yeah he took over my grandfather's
business um
in like steel they had to steal
that's that oh that's that old money
steal
i think he's still into the business he
just
oh
let me ask you a question though um off
that subject
um so with the pandemic and everything's
going so i see how my business
and i you know we just shut down i'm
doing these weird zoom
shows and weird like parking lot shows
you know i hate it but i do it because i
love comedy
but do you think there's going to be
fashion modeling uh in the in the future
or
there already is like there's a huge
segment
of these past shows this month of
fashion week shows that are all virtual
um
either on their like websites or youtube
yeah but how are they doing how are they
doing they're not
are models going to do them yeah they're
hiring models
um and it's just they you know there's
no audience
and they just do it without oh right
right right
and they i mean it looks like
from what my friends have done it looks
like um
they're the only ones who aren't that
don't have to wear a mask
and so everyone else around them is
wearing a mask or
they're wearing a mask yeah it goes with
the outfit
or um or they're wearing a mask
until like a minute until the show then
take it off and go
oh um or uh there was i think
it was marc jacobs who did a puppet
fashion show
did you see that i thought i showed you
a little clip of it but
i was like i was surprised to see like
they also had like
the virtual or it's not even a real
person it's just like
you know i'm made up so that's like when
you saw that were you like uh oh
i mean i think it's great because i just
love fashion
even if i'm not involved in it i still
am obsessed with it
um like your scalar shirt that somebody
made for you yeah this is
my friend um well he's a designer
then became my friend um ian patrick
is everyone go follow him his instagram
is
a boy in his soy
um and i custom made this shirt
he was like what do you want i'll make
you something and i was like i want
really long sleeves and a little crab
and then my name
and so maybe he'll like i'll hit him up
and maybe he'll design something
more but
we'll see we'll get it what's his name
again ian what ian patrick we're getting
boy in his sword ian patrick original uh
roofing with griffin and make sure you
go to the riff of the griffin store
actually if you go to the website eric
griffin.com it's right there or in the
or in the i have a links down below it's
just a basic teespring store i get some
good art from some fans
i work it out with have made some
interesting stuff well well that's good
i mean if i don't know
i i i look at i never liked fashion
i never liked the the point the point of
it
you know it's like you see these like
i've come to your shows and i've seen
your pictures
and you always look beautiful in the
clothes like you make the cake yeah but
you just don't get it i don't
get it i don't get it like i've never
seen anyone in public wearing some of
the nonsense that you wear at these
fashion shows
what's the point of it please explain it
to me well it's art
eric and if you don't understand what
art is
oh here we go everybody then you will
never understand it it's art
it's art in a way of like it can express
how someone feels how someone like
wants to be portrayed sometimes they
want to be
all black and gothic and be like i'm sad
i'm
you know mourning or so sometimes
they're like i'm
colorful like sunshine on a spring day
and wear
pink and orange but wait wait wait let
me let me i'm not to cut you off but i
just want to get make it
okay so when you say it like that so i
understand so like some of these dresses
and outfits that these designers put out
it's not necessarily to be like
mass produced in macy's and jc penney's
it's just for this moment to show
the to express whatever then there's
some of them that are going to be like
correct okay yes that's what a fashion
show is about the
the extreme version of fashion and then
what happens
is people are like like nordstroms or
the buyers or
whoever it is no one's going to wear
this and so they're like let's
let's tone it down they'll wear these
pants without all the ruffles and then
so that's what
gets made like
so they make a splash they make a splash
with the weird stuff
and then they go well this is my other
yeah from my line
or they wait and see what everyone loves
in the line like they have all this
crazy stuff and then they're like okay
well everyone loved this
thing and so then the trend
whatever like big shoulders or like
high rise pants so how do you stay in
the know
about fashion is it just strictly so now
with the internet are you just always
going to like like where do you go if
you want if you wanted to know what was
in season
what do you do i would go to youtube
and or you go to the designers
um fashion show so you could see all
their
looks you could either go to their
websites and see all their
um looks just like
pin nailed i know but that seems such a
like an extensive research thing
i'm sorry i could actually watch the
show i know but even before that i'm
just saying just in general
yeah they talk about integrity like
interviews
no no but what i'm saying i'm talking
about in general
if you're like oh what's in now like
what sort of jeans should i be wearing
and
what sort of pants should i be right
what's the color scheme that's in that
game like
how does someone how does someone figure
that out you're asking
me how i do mine or you're asking how
anyone
does it well well okay i get how you do
that because
rachel's big on like when we were
getting her car
just for for a week the youtube was on
on the tv of like car comparisons
that's how you do it you're big on you
do research that way
the majority of people look at
celebrities they look at
um you know what
cardi b is wearing what nicki minaj is
wearing what
you know like all their famous um
you know celebrities magazines so the
trend the trendsetters
yeah um you know justin bieber what's he
wearing you know like
and where does that and where do you
think that that starts from so is that
like
so is there a pipeline from the the
major
designers and stores and brands like
nike ralph lauren and all these kind of
places
so they want to make sure they get those
clothes and stuff
into people that are high profile right
i mean like some of the big designers
like
right now bella hadid is in every single
advertisement for every single designer
which means like
if she's the face of what's cool then
it's like okay well
whoever likes her is going to be like
well she's wearing this designer so now
i could wear that designer and that's
going to be in
huh i didn't know who that was when we
because we saw that great
yeah i didn't even i didn't even know
she had a brand her fenty brand i didn't
even know that that was her brand but
she had this great
show it's like a it's it's almost like a
doc it's something
it's like a choreographed dance with
like a big video
surprise guest of models yeah it was
like
and artists yeah but it was very happy
very very art very artistic so it was
like a real
well-produced fashion show documentary
type of thing about her fashion line
and she's very body conscious so it's
like all
different types of sizes uh transgender
you know right so it's very very yeah
like
um after watching that
that was a virtual fashion show yeah
yeah yeah for sure so
like that's hopefully more coming out of
that
uh i see what you're saying yeah it was
very i thought it was great just they
had this great imagery
in it too like there was there was a
girl you know she was
she's very in shape dancer but she's
dancing in front of a fun house
mirror so in the mirror it was like all
distorted
and it was like good imagery of like oh
this is what people see when they look
in the mirror and it's just all that
kind of stuff and
she's but it was like all lingerie too
though but she has a men's line
yeah there's a men's line of clothing
that wasn't you know obviously not
lingerie it was like long pants and
weird
open shirts and stuff but yeah i mean i
i again i now i see what you're saying
more now so you would look at that kind
of thing and be like
oh you would look at that and be like oh
i want i want that i want this and then
people go out to like the stores and
find
but how does it get to like fancy places
to like
jc penney's how does it filter down
well okay i'm not exactly sure
okay okay that's a fair answer but
what's your what's your guess what i
think
happened is um
well like with rihanna's fenty stuff
it's like that's all
very reasonable price stuff and it was
directly on her website so you could
literally
like same with i did a fashion show for
the brand cotton
and same with their show it was like i
think it was
the first virtual show that you could
watch the fashion show it was in new
york
and um you could directly buy the
clothes
on or not um
amazon prime oh oh they had an amazon
store yeah you can literally watch the
show and buy the clothes at the same
time and that was
like that was two years ago maybe
three years ago yeah i guess so and
yeah that amazon alexa she
she started our show
[Laughter]
welcome to whatever yeah and it was so
cool and i remember
whatever i was wearing sold immediately
like that day that night
oh [ __ ] because i remember i was like
i'm gonna buy my outfit
but um and so it's kind of cool that's
great when it's affordable for you
because you could be like finally i can
afford exactly like it's crazy if you
could afford it
and you could just automatically buy it
it's a new
it's a whole new yeah which is much
better because you always would complain
like you're wearing a 8 000
dress that you can never buy oh right
you watch chanel or gucci
and some women can't afford it yeah yeah
some men can afford it
and it's just like me watching the fenty
video and be like i can afford that 20
thing you know we were in new york uh
rachel and i were in new york for
fashion week
this past we were in february
the last real fashion week yeah the last
fashion week but i mean you even told me
you're like let's just do a hurrah
because i was like i don't know if i
want to go back to new york yeah because
you were working
you know
dropped the whole runway division so i
didn't have
an agent and i was kind of like i don't
know if i want to do this
but i knew there were a few designers
do it yeah i don't regret it yeah it was
great
i used i used my airline miles i i had i
had points at the marriott
we actually did it up but i just feel
like but my point is like it was right
before
this coronavirus scare what's going on i
think
people knew about it i didn't know about
it you know i don't know about it
i didn't know about it to the extent
that it is right now
you know and i even think like you know
it's just who knows like you if you were
in new york in february
and you were feeling sick or whatever
you might have had it and i
didn't even know i think a lot of people
before that
if they didn't know what it was yet i
think at that point
anybody could have had a i even feel
like i could have had it already in the
in the past and been like didn't realize
i could have been asymptomatic and
whatever you know it's just weird how
i look back at that trip like damn that
was the la i don't know i don't even
know when we're even gonna go to new
york again
yeah i don't even want to go near new
york right now
we have some good times in new york what
are you talking about yeah no i love you
it's like this third place i'd want
what's the second place um like
really tampa i loved it was nice
you could like swim in the ocean every
day tampa
episode ghetto no offense no offense to
you people out there in tampa
you know i i love all of
did you go swimming in the ocean when
you went with tampa guy yeah that's what
i meant like it was
beautiful beautiful water beautiful
weather
it rained a little bit and i did get
some bug bites that i'm not
wow that's why i love california less
less bug bites yeah rachel's total
california
but i was born and raised
all the people like a lot of my friends
are leaving but they're not originally
from here that's why
i instantly like fell
for you because you were a california
boy and i was like okay he's not gonna
want
and that's a you know a lot of people
come here
live here for a few years and then
they're like okay or
because because it didn't work out too
people come here for like
i want to be a such and such and it
didn't work out
the cost of living is so high then
they're just like well they
hey i gotta go home or i gotta go
someplace else a lot of people are
moving to nashville i mean even your
friend matt came over and he was like
i just wanna meet a girl and then move
to ohio yeah yeah
like go to ohio and meet the girl
someone who wants to live in ohio no he
wants to take a beautiful california
girl
and then transplant her to ohio so
nobody could get it
he's going to be trying a very long time
oh man well listen uh this is i'm glad
this is another great segment with my
beautiful fiancee
rachel um you know i i want to have you
on
more i'm glad you're being more
comfortable thanks for being open
well i mean i hope your fans understand
why i cried it's not because no i get it
even if they don't get it i don't really
i
[Laughter]
i can't wait to see what the comments
are going to be about like oh you know
they just they're just so
like their lives are so worthless some
of them that they just have to find a
way to dig
at people but it's just so funny to me
because when i see those things and i
just think about like how
not it is like that just because one i
like
i don't want to i don't want a dependent
i wanted a partner and so that's why
rachel works and she whatever
she spends their money on the things
that she wants because she earns it you
know
and then i help one of the things that i
want to help with because we're a couple
we're
we're working together on it so it's
great so maybe you too can find someone
that is
the person of your dreams like i did
well thank you for having me again i
know what the last two episodes
you're doing you're doing that thing now
i didn't cut you out i just don't want
people to get used to it i wanted to see
like
you know what i really wanted to see i
wanted to see like do they really still
like me or is it like just like rachel
like
like you you know and from the numbers i
was like oh man i got to get you back on
again
well you know i think it also had to do
with i was like you know telling my
family and my friends like
did you watch the episode i'm in it
listen i'm sure those 11 people didn't
make that
didn't make the thing no no and this
one's all like
hey people are asking why i'm not on the
podcast i have fans now
shout out to that one person you know
who you are
i don't want to hear about your pervert
fans actually he's a fan of yours
and he's still a pervert whoever he is
if he's hitting you up he's a pervert
um but anyways this has been my rachel
rachel moment
uh i always i don't wanna i don't know
why i always called it
relationship update but forget that this
is we're gonna call it what i always
wanted
well uh this has been another segment of
rachel's corner and
i'll see you guys i think i would get to
sit in the corner
she wants to switch these because she
this is her good side so next time we do
rachel's corner i'll be sitting over
there and she'll be sitting over here
all right you happy yeah we just need to
get a picture of you
so i
since day one trust me
so if you have some art you want to draw
rachel send us some art the po box is
right there and i also want to thank the
people that have sent things to the p.o
box i've actually gotten
but i've gotten some great art from
people um i've gotten some uh
some books somebody sent me a really
great book about dementia you know
because i know you guys know about my
mom
so i really appreciate that and uh i
wish i had some
the thing that i'll do i'll show you
next week so somebody drew me in our
picture
probably he probably watches a podcast
and it's like this guy's never mentioned
this thing
so i will show it next week it's a some
handmade art
and if you two want to send me things uh
you could the po box is right there in
the description
and anyways um thanks for again babe i
love you
and yeah she's gonna get to work she
gotta get to work so
uh he's a gold digger
yeah she's my sugar mama hey guys i'm
here once again to talk to you about
helix sleep they got the best mattresses
in town
are you having trouble sleeping you got
some old saggy mattress you have some
old hand-me-down mattress you don't even
know where you got your mattress from is
it the mattress from your childhood
listen you're an adult now it's time for
you to get a big boy mattress
get your big girl mattress and you're
going to get it from helix sleep
i mean i understand right now it's
trouble we live in troubled times we got
this pandemic on our mind we got
politics we got so many things there's
stress and anxiety we don't know when
we're gonna
go back to work we don't know if we're
gonna go be able to sit inside
restaurants so
you need sleep sleep is one of the most
important things for
good physical and mental health
helix sleep knows this helix sleep has
this uh two minute quiz all right it's
perfect it's great
i took it i haven't got my mattress yet
but i took the quiz
and i'm excited for it and i'll be
talking about it even more in future
episodes but helix sleep has a quiz that
takes just two minutes to complete and
matches your body type
and sleep preference to the perfect
mattress for you
look everybody's unique right we all got
different body shapes and sizes we all
sleep different and helix knows this
so they have several different mattress
models to choose from look they got
soft they got medium they got firm they
got mattress that's great for
cooling you down or if you sleep hot or
even if you
are a plus size person they have
mattresses for you too they got
mattresses for everybody so i'm
super excited i love the quiz portion of
it i've never even done that before you
know you go to the mattress store and
you're like you go hey can i lay down on
this
and you're kind of like sitting there
and you're like huh how is this
different from any other mattress you
don't know
but helix takes that into account and
they customize the mattress for you
you take the sleep quiz look i took the
quiz and i can't wait for my mattress to
come alright
i got medium because i sleep on my side
and my shoulders hurt so
it's going to be soft i run hot so it's
going to be cool
i'm really excited for it and i really
highly recommend you guys go to helix
sleep because
everything i've read about it everything
i see about it this is a place to go to
get the best
mattress in town in your town in any
town because you can order it
right to your home all right this is
very important just go to helixsleep.com
griffin that's important once again go
to helixsleep.com
griffin take their two minute sleep quiz
and they'll match you to the customized
mattress that will give you the best
sleep of your life
helix is offering up to two hundred
dollars off all mattress orders and two
free pillows for our listeners
at helixsleep.com griffin hey
guys take advantage of this and go get
the best sleep of your life let's get
back to the show
yeah what's up guys and we're back uh
that was my beautiful lady
rachel she'll be on the podcast more and
you know just i also want to say uh
i do have a patreon uh don't have a lot
of
people you know it's very little very
handful of people who are on my patreon
but
for me i haven't actually done a lot of
stuff for it but i am going to start
doing that now
i'm going to be doing more i'm going to
do like a little weekly sub
episode that'll just be for patreon
and also just some little videos that
rachel and i are gonna be doing and
it'll be strictly just for that
for patreon and for my youtube members
too so you could be a youtube member or
patreon either or
i'm gonna put those same videos up for
those people
to see and we'll you know we'll see
we'll try i'm just trying to grow put
out
extra content and see you know see what
we can get done so if you're interested
in that
you can go to my patreon for that but
once again i appreciate when rachel
comes on
you guys seem to like it when rachel
comes on so she's getting more
comfortable right i hope so
uh she's you know she seemed awkward at
first and then now she's getting more
comfortable with it because that was
like a one-shot recording usually
sometimes she's like i need to do it
again i want to see what i look like
i can't just go on i want to see it so
we did it but
anyway uh not a lot this week on this
week's episode uh you know i wanted to
have rachel we had our long talk uh
longer than i thought we were gonna have
so that's great
and then but i just wanted to uh catch
up with my big brother fans
people that are fans of big brother if
you're not a fan of big brother you can
stop now
if you are a fan of big brother this is
it for you right here so
big brother if you've never watched big
brother big brothers like they start
with like 16 or 20 people
uh usually beautiful in shape people and
they live in a house and they have to
compete against conte
compete against each other in these
different contests
along with living in the house 24 hours
a day being filmed 24 hours a day
to win 500 000 and the whole point of it
is people
have to lie and scheme and make deals
and they just
they backstab each other and it's just a
really bizarre
show and it really brings out the worst
in human nature uh
and then you you know for money right so
it's just a train wreck but
i only started watching the show like
like maybe like four for the last four
or five seasons
so i you know this is the all-star
season it's just and it's been so
lackluster like i just don't get so this
one guy cody uh he won the very first
head of household and he's just been
cleaning house he's never been on the
block
and he's you know he's won like six or
seven competitions
uh the the voting for veto and all this
stuff right he's won all these
competitions and no one's taking a shot
at him
so i just want to get caught up to where
we are now at big brother is like
they should have gone after him so this
girl nicole who was a previous winner
which i don't understand how they let
her skate through up to this point right
now
she's a previous winner i mean she's a
huge threat because if she
because what happens is all right so the
the final six people i believe that get
kicked out of the house
they actually are the jury who vote for
who the winner is gonna be
so a lot of times what i've witnessed is
it's a lot of bitter
bitch-ass jury members they're just
[ __ ] you know they they're so
they they got outplayed they got out
maneuvered and then they want to act up
and so they don't
vote for the right person to win like
paul should have won
two seasons ago he should have won when
he came back on
uh that guy that one should not have won
nicole shouldn't have won against paul
either it's just people were bitter
because they got they got played
tyler should have won you know and so
they finally got him out this season but
i wanted him to win
um i just like him he just he just comes
across as a cool dude
uh i like his gameplay i like how he
played so you know
and he was right to try to get nicole
out right so you know so
him and christmas who i can't stand i
i'm just not a fan of christmas
she's she her against anybody left in
the house
final two she is no one's gonna vote for
her you know unless they're bitter right
but
even in this the way people have played
they've kind of played a pretty
fair game you know uh like the guy that
just got kicked out
as of this podcast was the guy memphis
and he's just a snake
but he was playing the game right but he
just really thought he was smarter than
he really was
you know he he made like two separate
deals and he didn't know that those
people were
paired up from the beginning you know so
he got blindsided and he was shocked by
it but he shouldn't have been like he
was
lying to people the whole time the way
he was so bitter about that was just
hilarious you know
bitter justice for him so he got kicked
out good riddance
but anyways here's what really ticked me
off
okay so
nicole wins head of household
all right she puts up christmas
and memphis the two other guys left are
enzo and cody who she's
working with okay so
now she wants to send home memphis
all right enzo and cody are the only two
votes okay so they so ultimately no
matter what she wants
they actually decide now she goes to
christmas and she says to her
like i really don't want you to go even
though you tried to get me out
i think they're starting to see that
these guys are gonna beat them
so they're trying to team up now to make
it to the end and i think it's tomorrow
nicole because i'm nicole sitting next
to christmas in the end
nicole's gonna win again all right uh
christmas is just
she just doesn't have it you know um
all right so to me
what
nicole should have done is
she should have and then she won the
power of veto so nicole wins power veto
she wins head of house so she wins provo
veto so she supposedly has all the power
so she keeps noms the same but to me
what she
should have done is she should have put
up
she should have taken christmas off the
block
and put enzo or cody on the block
and then told christmas you vote
how i want because
enzo for sure would have voted for
memphis to go
and she would say to cody christmas i
want you to vote for cody so i can make
the choice
that would have been a boss move that
would have been a boss move or she
should have put ends either one she
should have taken christmas off the
block put up cody or enzo
a real boss move would have been to send
cody home
that would have been the move right
there because that guy if he's sitting
next to anybody left
if you're in the jury you're like wow
yeah this guy was great he played us the
whole time
he won all the competitions he should
win the 500 thousand dollars
so if you want a chance to win you got
to get rid of that guy
that was nicole's chance and the games
just that the show's boring and the
game's weak because of that
like that would have been the bosses
move ever
take christmas off you tell christmas
who you want her to vote for
you know you tell her vote for cody to
go
because enzo was going to vote for
memphis it would have been tied
and then she makes the choice and then
she could have stood up there and said
look cody i love you we've been playing
together
but i can't beat you in the final two so
i'm sending you home now that would have
been
historic epic big brother move
but you think they do that no they don't
do those kind of moves right now
it's just a lot of safe nonsense you
know
and um you know the people in the jury
house so they sent uh tyler home and i
like that devon
and tyler had like a little powwow
because
um tyler uh was feeling a certain way
because he was you know trying to make
moves and he put a target on
bailey and devon the two black girls in
the house
and he felt bad about how they were now
being targeted
and so the christmas was the head of
household at the time
and so he goes to christmas and says
listen take one of them off the block
and put me up because i just want to go
home
and then she says that's not going to
help my game
you know christmas was like nah man
you're not i'm not going to be the one
to do your dirty work because you know
you're
you're staying cuz you help me you help
with my game
and he you know sure enough then that
came across as like he was actually
playing them so they were all mad at him
you know and then so they end up um
you know they end up like devon and
bailly and get
sent home and then tyler stays so it
looks so they had like a little
pow wow in the uh jury house and i
really believe him i think he's a
genuine dude you know
he plays the game he played the game the
way he's supposed to play he lied just
enough i mean it's all lies and deceit
like he's the only one that came up with
a boss move
so the week before the week before
you know that so it's like you know uh
nicole's on the block it was a triple
eviction
so nicole's on the block and so it's
like all they need is three votes to
send nicole home
so he says he gets christmas and goes
let's send her home you know
christmas is like all for it let's do it
tyler's all for it let's do it
tyler goes to enzo and he's like yo man
i think we should make a big move right
now i think we should send her home
enzo [ __ ] out like it's hilarious
that he thinks he's gonna win the way
he's playing i mean that's
just the funniest part about it when i
watch it i watch this guy
thinking that he's making big moves if
he's sitting next to
anyone they're gonna they're gonna be
like well what did you actually do
what's your record other than
riding the coattails of your buddy now
if he gets down to the final three
and he sends cody home that'll be a boss
move
you know cody won't vote for him but
that'll be a boss move
right but other than that there's
nothing that he's done to make you want
to vote so anyways
he turns on christmas and cody leaves
christmas and tyler
leaves them out to dry so now it the
vote was two to three when it was
supposed to be unanimous to send home
i believe it was david but either way
nicole's like whoa
two people voted against me and there's
only you know six people left
so you know it's easy to go okay and so
that's why she figured it out and then
tyler was on her radar
and so the next week uh you know they uh
cody puts up tyler and
um christmas the two people that voted
against nicole
and of course they sent tyler home which
was the right move uh ultimately
ultimately it was the right move um but
tyler made a compelling case i really
feel like
because he was saying look if christmas
wins next week dude she's gonna put you
up
and who's to vote for you because then
it'll be memphis and memphis would for
sure send cody home
but it worked out in their favor because
nicole won but that's the thing about
big brother you never know what's going
to happen in the end you never know like
who's going to win head of household
at the right particular time you know
like somebody some monkey wrench can get
thrown in like if christmas wins the
head of household next week
that would just like mess up everybody
because then she's gonna put up cody and
enzo or she'll put up
yeah she'll put up cody and enzo and
then they'll have to win the power of
veto
and then the thing is it'll just be
those two votes
and then so like whoever wins power of
veto next week is
in a boss position to send somebody home
because there's only four people left
so one had a household two nominees and
there's
one vote okay and then the other person
the head of household
actually gets to decide who goes home so
next week is the most crucial head of
household so
i don't know man i just wish you know a
few big brother fans i just wish they
would make like
real decisive big boy moves but you know
they don't
so it's pretty whack man i tell you a
show that i started watching
because you know you guys know how i
love 90 day fiance the other way
90 day the other way you know and it's
getting crazy right now so another
couple
another couple wait let me let me let me
uh let me get this couple
okay so i cut away because i was i
couldn't find the damn cast but here
they are right here
so this other couple tim and mel melzer
meliza or malaysia i don't know what the
hell her colombian name is
but you know they out here in uh
you know he moved to colombia of course
he cheated on her
you know and then you know he
he's going to to talk to the family he
can't he speaks spanish he's trying to
get a job he can't get a job
then it turns out she cheated on him too
probably as revenge but it's like
that doesn't solve anything so
everybody's cheating so it's just
another like crazy but anyways
the reason why i bring it up so they got
so the from season like
nowadays fiance um there was
you know this couple chantel
and i forgot the guy's name you know
so they actually did a spin-off show
um yeah they did they did they did a
spin-off show of this
chantel and pedro chantal and pedro so
they were just a volleyball couple but
they wanted these couples that like they
look good
so there's another reason why the whole
[ __ ] is crazy uh so you know like
so you know they're hot they're good
they're both good looking you know
uh and so you go okay well what's going
on here so they keep saying that he's
using her for money that he's using her
for some like
you know some kind of like uh for visas
or something
that's what the family thinks and so of
course the families had a big fight they
actually
had a fist fight where the two people
attacked each other like
chantel's brother river
and pedro got into it at some family
function and they hadn't seen each other
so
it was so volatile and so crazy that
they decided to make a spin-off show
called
the family chantelle and i got to tell
you guys
chantelle's family is the most
ignorant stupid
embarrassing people i've i've ever seen
on television now
either they're playing it up for the
camera
which one if that were the case they're
coming across
as ignorant just complete
idiots now if they're playing it up for
that case i don't understand the point
of that because
you don't look at them with like any
kind of respect or
they actually are the stupidest people
you've ever met in your life
like just you've ever seen like the way
they act the way
the things that come out of their mouth
the way they're like
portraying themselves it's just like it
you want to talk about hate watching
some television shows
i mean i hate watch the hell out of the
family chantel
at this point too like i don't they're
so
dumb that i'm on pedro's side most of
the time
so like he's off with his friends and
they go dancing whatever it is and some
girl is grinding up on him and dancing
and whatnot
and then the sister shows her you look
pedro is like i don't know why this
pedro sister showed her this stuff
you know and so now
she tells her family and her family's
like we going over there
the mom grabs a taser okay this [ __ ]
brought a taste
don't even get me i wish rachel's mom
would come over my house with a taser
you know what i mean like please please
i wish you would come over here with a
taser you know what i mean
like it don't even get me started
anyways the
they go over there just barge in
unannounced and they want to know what's
going on
what what are you doing like the way
they did it it's like this is just
completely inappropriate like the girl
herself
handle your business like go talk to
your husband if you've already handled
if he's already talked to you about this
it was like like this was nothing it was
innocent or
look i'm sorry that you you feel
disrespected uh
it got out of hand but nothing other
than happen other than that
either however you gonna deal with it
that's between husband and wife
they deal with that she gonna come over
with the taser and they all
they storming in his in the apartment
and the mom's like i'm not leaving make
me leave you ain't gonna make me leave
that kind of ignorant [ __ ] is like
get
out of here man get out of here so
and that's just one or two episodes that
i've seen and i was like wow
i love hate watching
that show because everything they do
infuriates me because they're
so stupid like you
have to watch it because you're gonna be
like
how do people is this how people conduct
themselves
like you know a lot of these shows you
go
this has got to be contrived like a lot
of this is like fake or like the
producers are going hey maybe you should
fight with her or you feel
like you kind of feel like i don't know
if this is real
this is one of these shows where i go
why would you want
at the end of the day if when you look
back on this show
if they're looking back on this going
like oh we we came across
good then i feel sorry for them you know
what i mean or if they look back on the
show
like why aren't they looking back on the
show going oh man i didn't realize
i was acting a fool like that like
people that don't know they act in a
fool
and then they see the footage if they
don't have no remorse i'm like what
what what's going on in your life like
all these shows are like this
man they're all like this so i don't
know i'm gonna keep you posted on the
family chantel
uh i'm cause i want to finish the whole
season and then really delve into like
how dumb this is
but i'm also again i'm gonna keep track
of big brother because the end is near
and i'd
really love to see who wins i just want
somebody to make a big move you know
i want somebody to make a big move but
look anyways um we're gonna finish up
listen i don't have any advice uh no
advice segment this week i'm it's gonna
come back next week so look out for my
instagram post
some people have been sending me emails
and stuff like that but i think i'm
gonna create an email specifically for
that
and don't forget i twitch every single
day i twitch and i put my videos also up
on youtube and that's eric griffin
gaming on both
eric griffin gaming so watch me do that
i'm really having fun doing that
and uh you know i'm having fun doing the
podcast and like i say look out for some
more
personal in-depth content on my patreon
channel
uh me and rachel doing more little mini
episodes and
uh i'm also gonna start doing bonus
episodes during the week too so i'm
trying to do
more content as possible for you so
instead of doing one episode a week i
think i'm gonna start doing
two episodes a week coming out on
wednesdays and uh you know so maybe i'll
do this regular like right
there's a hodgepodge of things me and
rachel talking and i still have guests
coming in uh on this one and then just
have like my
you know like it'll be like a 20 30
minute of like if i want to talk about a
particular show it'll be
that i'll do it on that episode so you
know let's see uh
if we can finally start to get some
growth
listen i appreciate the fans that are
here but you know i need to get some
more fans so
i love your ideas and suggestions and
all that kind of stuff too so and i do
appreciate you guys watching riffing
with griffin
listening every week sharing subscribing
please keep doing that follow me on it
on instagram and twitter
i'm on those things so make sure you
check me out there too
and i really like i say i appreciate you
guys being here every single week
uh and i'll see you next
you